et avec moi en plateau notre chroniqueur
international gauthier rybinski nous a
rejoints bonjour gauthier jours antoine
je voulais revenir à gauthier avec vous
sur ce qu'on évoquait sur ses éventuels
pourparlers en tout cas qui pourraient
se dérouler dans les toutes prochaines
heures voire même des toutes prochaines
minutes entre délégations russe et
ukrainienne comment interpréter selon
selon vous cette volonté négociations
gauthier ce que c'est une une réelle
volonté de négocier ou est ce que c'est
que cherchent les russes et surtout les
ukrainiens dans ces négociations
première remarque ce qui est étrange si
vous voulez c'est que ces négociations
aient lieu entre les deux seuls partis
la russie et l'ukraine on a compris ces
jours derniers et même depuis plus
longtemps que la russie avait un
objectif d'ailleurs vladimir poutine
l'avait dit il avait dit je ne veux pas
la guerre avec l'ukraine bien c'est la
duplicité habituel de vladimir poutine
mais on avait compris à travers sa
caisse qu'il visait c'était évidemment
une négociation de larges de grande
envergure sur la question de la supposée
sécurité de la russie donc là on se
demande sur quoi il est possible de
négocier vous l'avez rappelé les
ukrainiens n'ont pas l'intention de
capituler la russie a encore remonte
encore d'un cran lorsque par exemple
vladimir poutine parle de mise en alerte
de de la dissuasion
on va y revenir là effectivement il
essayons d'imaginer deux sur coup on
peut négocier
négocier ça veut dire par exemple dans
l'état actuel des choses que la russie
accepterait de ne pas poursuivre sa
marche jusqu'à la frontière occidentale
de l'ukraine par exemple frontières qui
est à côté d'élèves qui est la frontière
polono ukrainienne est ce que quand on
dit quand par exemple admire poutine
affirme qu'il veut la démilitarisation
de l'ukraine est ce que c'est compatible
avec cela pas forcément je dirais que
d'une manière générale à 7,2
donc dans la compréhension que nous
avions du personnage de vladimir poutine
c'est à dire d'un personnage rationnelle
ce type de négociation est concevable
nous savons bien que depuis le
déclenchement de cette guerre nous avons
les plus grands doutes sur les capacités
de vladimir poutine à raisonner de
manière rationnelle
donc ces négociations sont quelque peu
obscure pour les ukrainiens ça peut être
un moment aussi de répit de souffle et
d'envisager des des ajustements
tactiques de repositionner par exemple
telle et telle bataille on y compris
lorsqu'il s'agit de bataillon de civils
qui n'ont pas l'habitude précisément
d'être au combat et qu'il faut encadrer
est ce que il y a un espoir quelconque
que par exemple les troupes russes
arrêtent leur progression vers kiev
écoutez je pense que n'importe qui de
normalement constitué le souhaiterait
mais enfin ce que viennent nous dire que
clovis casali sur les la nuit qui vient
de se dérouler et la journée également
n'incite pas à l'optimisme
ou bien encore effectivement c'est une
façon de garder des cartouches pour la
russie qui dit si nous pouvons pas
négocier eh bien ça sera kiev on prendra
kiev immédiatement donc là encore ce
genre de posture nécessite que l'autre
que l'adversaire soit accessible à la
raison effectivement on pourrait vous
allez me dire ce marchandage est
horrible mais ça peut être concevable à
partir du moment où il n'y a pas ou il
n'y a plus cet accès à la raison on ne
peut pas savoir exactement ce qu'il en
est et encore une fois je remarque
d'ailleurs que d'une manière assez je ne
sais pas si ceux-ci ici c'est une ironie
de l'histoire ou pas mais l'endroit où
doivent se dérouler ces négociations
c'est-à-dire à la frontière je sais pas
on a une carte peut être mon année carte
on l'a vu d'ailleurs vous gelin ses
passions pas la remettre une carte qui
indique voilà on va la voir elle arrive
voilà alors vous voyez donc cette cette
zone ici qui est la zone de tchernobyl
et three pyatt c'est à la fois où prévu
c'est le lieu où époux où sont prévues
les négociations mais pire c'est à la
fois un fleuve mais c'est également une
ville qui fait partie de ce cercle comme
gomel en biélorussie qui sont dans la
zone d'exclusion la zone contaminée on a
été surpris effectivement que ces
derniers jours les soldats russes se
soit emparé de tchernobyl bon il y avait
une raison majeure c'est que c'est sur
la route de kiev de kiev mais en même
temps compte tenu du danger que cela
représente parce que le sarcophage de
tchernobyl nécessite une maintenance
absolue c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas
se passer de le surveiller pour des
raisons dont qui ont trait à la
longévité de la menace et des radiations
donc on est tenu de se demander pourquoi
tout en sachant justement que la
possession d'un site comme tchernobyl
l'occupation de ce site comme tchernobyl
c'est aussi l'occupation d'un site à
déchets et vous savez que le concept de
sale guerre ça existe aussi c'est à dire
se servir de déchets nucléaires pour
faire pression sur / ho / sur mon ennemi
sur son adversaire gauthier d'un mot on
vient de l'apprendre le président zen ce
qui lui a fait quelques déclarations il
affirme justement que leurs buts lors de
ces négociations de ces pourparlers
celle à l'intégrité territoriale de
l'ukraine donc encore une fois peut-être
un une indication sur la teneur de ces
de ses éventuels
pourparlers et qu'il dit prêt dans une
haine ce qui qui dit voilà le qui dit
que la protection inconditionnelle de
l'état et l'inde est l'un de ses
objectifs donc on voit déjà que les
ukrainiens pose les bases de des futures
négociations un oui alors tout à fait cc
c'est conforme à ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure sur l'avs la volonté de ne pas
capituler là dessus à quoi peut servir
peuvent servir ces négociations à la
russie si ce n'est de dire nous avons
tenté quelque chose et ça ne marche pas
donc vous voyez c'est parfois les
négociations sont un faux prétexte cela
dit quand il ya une occasion de la sorte
dans un conflit pareil faut pas non plus
la bouder ce serait se serait-il
responsable donc on verra ce qui se
passe ce qui serait intéressant mais là
c'est encore un peu trop tôt c'est de
savoir pourquoi la russie si ces
négociations lieu la direction russe
plutôt accepte le principe de ces
négociations est ce que c'est un moyen
dilatoire tactique ou bien est ce qu'il
y a peut-être la prise de conscience de
la gravité de la situation et des enjeux
on va voir parce que il y a juge d'un
beau il y a un peu des frictions mais
des quelques dissensions au sein de la
direction russe sur la manière dont tout
ça est
et